again
[Music]
right so Walter who are you uh voting
for for mayor of la oh wow that's fast I
don't vote in L.A because I don't live
in L.A dude you got a boat or die bro
yeah you gotta vote how come you don't
vote what are you P Diddy you gotta Vote
or Die yeah I don't I don't I don't live
it they don't they don't allow non-la
residents to vote for LA mayor I don't
know if you understand how that works
because you live in OC yeah that's true
I do oh wow that's where all the cool
Koreans live I can't believe you drive
all the way out here for this dude
I think what he's saying is thank you
oh yeah thanks for coming home
well who do you uh do you guys know
who's running for mayor who's up for the
two like the two main candidates from
Rich dude and some black lady yeah
that's all I know okay okay guess their
names now the billionaire Rich dude
right yeah yeah one's uh one's a Caruso
one's a Debbie or Deborah one's a Debbie
yeah Debbie Downer it's uh yeah it's
Rick Caruso and Karen bass yeah
I seen that name but they both have I
think one of the most important things
right now is everybody wants to know
what their plans are for the homeless
situation that's kind of like because
that's one of the biggest issues we're
[ __ ] dealing with yeah so what's Rick
Caruso gonna do well Rick Caruso being
probably one of the richest people to
ever run for me this guy's like a net
worth of four Bill wow he's uh he's a he
owns like so much real estate and like a
bunch of different things just put them
on his real estate then yeah got so much
real estate that's okay that's hold that
point because it's really pretty funny
so um this dude he he built the Grove he
built like Americana a bunch of other
like really put them in the Americana oh
yeah
keep them at the Grove put them at the
Grove right now in in L.A alone there's
oh there's maybe around like 45
000 homeless people that's not that much
there's probably more yeah
but that's the count they're using for
you know but there's definitely more
there's definitely more what's the
official term you're supposed to use
unhoused in the house no I think there's
even more like even more PC yeah really
more unhoused neighbors yeah but Street
neighbors Street neighbors oh Street
neighbors is it outdoor living by choice
yeah it sounded some more like that
really City campers I don't know dude I
live in the Capitol you'd be hearing
some crazy terms I want to know the
cleanest possible like PC tournament do
you think they I don't think it's
unhoused I think it's do you think
unhoused people really give [ __ ] you
mean this is like how latinx people
don't call themselves latinx it's urban
camping
now
but then Tyler Creator got a problem
with the word Urban in the industry
anyway because you know what I mean what
about Suburban no we already decided I
think you can use urban when you're
using it right we're gonna start calling
it I hope so no one yeah when you're
talking about a city not wearing FUBU
yeah yeah
remember remember at one point we did
have UPN so I really feel like Urban
isn't about my God how can you remember
that it's so freaking Channel 13. Urban
People's network was that what it stood
for yeah they took on Buffy the Vampire
Slayer after the WB canceled it yeah
Urban about Buffy the Vampire Slayer
what's Urban about UPN it was a coup for
them to get Buffy because WB canceled
them and then but at that up to that
point there was I think all only
um black and Latinos on the shows on UPN
was hanging with Mr Cooper on my ABC on
Friday night well that wasn't on upm
what the hell was on UPN the magic hour
not much was on up is UPN just down here
I've never heard of that I feel like
cops it was our channel 13. channel 13
yeah up north I don't know what channel
it would have been I don't think maybe
by channel six you guys probably had
some good channels dude Channel 6 was
PBS where it's all like learner [ __ ]
yeah that was [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
TV channel uh [ __ ] uh Mr Rogers
Neighborhood what the [ __ ] was that put
it on the card again
he was trying to teach you how to Dougie
there's a key
someone needs to Loop that and put music
over machine it that way that's pretty
good yeah Mr Rogers was on there yeah so
we're agreed we're agreed that the PC
term from now on moving forward is
Suburban Commandos Suburban Commandos
with 45 000 homeless people everyone's
like what are your plans how are you
gonna take care of it
um obviously uh Rick Caruso his plan
involves a lot more money right now I
think the budget that they have
allocated for this currently stands at
like 300 mil for fixing this problem
which they aren't but with Rick Caruso's
plan he wants to kind of demolish the uh
sort of like the council that's been
[ __ ] holding everything up it's gonna
kick everyone out that's already not
gonna work because they're not moving
but his plan is he's gonna house I
believe 30 000 people within the first
year of being in office and it's gonna
cost almost 900 million dollars dude he
built the Grove he could do it is that
like hotels that's kind of true dude
interim housing so it could be it's like
kind of like transitionary places to
live and then there's some I believe
there are some permanent but most of
it's temporary you hear the hotel thing
where like uh I don't know if it's
California down here when the rooms
hotel room key yeah yeah they were gonna
force you to give them up to yeah I
think in Sacramento they're buying old
hotels redoing them and they're going to
try to get some housing in and then kind
of get you to go where you need to go
mental physical job you know whatever's
needed to right that's what kickstarted
which seems like a good plan I had a
politician I don't know [ __ ] but that's
part of the plan for both of them
they're both like I think that's just
kind of what you do I think Austin Texas
did it that's assuming that the like the
ones that want a place to live they'll
take it but there's a lot that don't
just want to stay outside that's that's
um some people not to be rude or to feel
like they're not on this planet yeah you
know that's you can't even like
like I feel like that's what you
normally try to do you're just trying to
go out to you know skid row and just
look at people like who's reading me
yeah so that's that's how you pick them
out huh so Caruso definitely has a lot
of uh money obviously he spent more on
his campaign than every other opponent
combined sick damn I suck I haven't seen
none of his campaigns he spend more
you're in Nevada get up over here and
watch [ __ ] cable TV
I know you're watching piano PBS with
your Mr Rogers
Mr Cooper so one thing is he is gonna
he's gonna declare a state of emergency
as soon as like he goes in office but
they have been saying you can't do that
because in order to do that you need the
approval of the council that you're
trying to [ __ ] erase what if he
racism then he doesn't either well you
can't he it won't happen like there's
just no way what are all these checks
and balances for anyway bro it's to keep
this problem [ __ ] going so they can
get paid bro damn what about Karen's
plan what's her so Karen's is is
different it's just a lot smaller I
think um hers she's she's in her first
year she thinks she'll do 17 000 people
indoors uh her plan is gonna cost 292
million
and a lot of it is using the current
stuff that was already supposed to
happen except she's gonna go in and make
sure it happens for realsies this time
that's what she said that's kind of what
her thing sort of of course both
politicians are gonna be pretty vague
because they want you to call them out
later when this [ __ ] doesn't happen but
her plan as Vegas it is does say she'll
use the existing system not dismantle it
as much as Caruso's trying to do but
she's gonna try to employ everything
that was supposed to happen but really
[ __ ] what kind of malls has she built
she's not built anymore not even a
Westfield not even a West here we've got
some Outlets she may have a [ __ ]
Guitar Center I love how he lists the
largest mall company in the world
generating more income yeah I'm like she
doesn't she hasn't contributed to the
malls she's already in politics I
believe she's like uh she's a house like
a rep or something or has she been
killing it or whatever she's doing I
don't know what that means so she's
already apologizing reps you know oh
repetitions three
erections just happened as soon as you
said reps she owns an orange theory
let's just say that so that way I could
get behind that I love their program she
brings her heart rate up yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think whatever politicians get in
office they should just make a a vowel
and they carry through that we stop
forming like committees and giving them
hundreds of millions of dollars to talk
yeah
because you guys know that I think it's
like 10 years ago we voted for a super
rail like bullet train I voted for that
LA to San Francisco yeah yeah I wish
they set aside 300 million just to talk
yeah
that's that's it and then they build it
from like Modesto to Fresno two places
no one wants to go
shout out to Modesto and Fresno so they
started
well they know their budget it ballooned
to I think two something billion but 300
million was allocated just to talk they
got some good talking though yeah that
was some great conversations and like
I'm like what just it's like if they can
eliminate that they'll all have and if I
ever moved to LA one day I'll I'll vote
for that person you're never gonna move
the main thing is a soft cost it's the
whole thing where um people let's say
you're given this budget right and then
you hire your guys right beneath you and
you just constantly keep paying them to
just consult yeah they don't actually
build anything so that's why like I
think with the the previous plan of like
here's how we're gonna attack
homelessness like 10 of it got done in
the course that they were supposed to
finish all of it and um it ballooned to
the fact that like the homes they were
making for homeless people cost more
than homes me and you could buy in the
market yeah like it got that high dude
it'd be like paying us 10 million
dollars
just doing what we're doing right now
great and we there's no action and we'd
be like hey we'll get you I think you're
on to something a discount five minutes
give us five million just to talk that's
basically what they're doing take more
dude you started with 10. I'm gonna run
for mayor worse than that it's paying us
it's paying us 10 million to talk about
someday doing this yes like we'll never
actually have cameras we'll just be like
hey wouldn't it be tight right all right
see you next week how would we do it so
that's main the main thing is that it
this to me it doesn't sound any
different than the last election
everyone's gonna say I can do this I'm
going to try to do this so far in
history California has a bad rap of who
do we believe more how do other cities
do it I heard uh Houston cleaned up
their homes in like six months or
something well so there's a guy that was
gonna run he was actually running for
mayor James uh Joe busque you know and
he used to be a cop and then uh he his
plan was very I mean it was pretty
ambitious but one thing in his plan that
the rest of these guys didn't have is he
said that I'm gonna put all these
resources out I'm gonna give them uh you
know place to stay attract to get of
mental help to get a job to put them on
like a a path they can actually become a
citizen of society but if they don't
want to do that I'm arresting them
oh wow that's kind of cool actually I
don't know if that works out here on the
way it's really why but just a [ __ ] not
me yeah yeah really yeah I think they're
too [ __ ] yeah I think a West Coast
because sometimes you just need like a
Asian mom in the back beating the [ __ ]
out of you and you kind of do what I
think Snuggery yeah I actually actually
hit up his [ __ ] person to be like hey
you want to come on JK I've come through
and they were like yeah and then he
dropped out of the race because he got
one percent [ __ ] like of the support
like people didn't want him because I
think his solution is to
um it's too mean it's too mean yeah you
know if Chris is the guy that did the
Grove I think he also has a place in
blender Pasadena I think it's if it's
the same guy his he does he does yeah
his father started Dollar Rent A Car and
so that's how he got started his his you
know Fame Fortune yeah but why I like
Caruso I'll say one thing is do you guys
remember when the college Scandal broke
out about people parents paying oh yeah
yeah yeah and then so one of them was
Lori Laughlin and her husband the
Massimo guy
her daughters were on the Culpo they
were on Caruso's yacht in Florida
because carusa's daughter is the same
age as Lori loughlin's out and they're
all friends
right before the story broke Caruso
called his daughter and goes get her off
the boat
now throw her get her get her off now
and then the story broke she was flying
back but then of course the word got out
that she was on cruises because Caruso
is the president of the um Board of
Trustees at USC and so he didn't want
anything to do he didn't want any
impropriety to do I'm like you know what
to me that's proactive
he's getting stuff done so if I were to
live in LA and vote I would vote are you
sure he didn't want off the boat because
just because maybe she couldn't swim
it could have been bad as well but I
don't want to go that far because she
was she got in on a fake rowing thing
she did I think she was did they call it
the coxson
I don't know
just yells
Paul that's called the coxin it's a
coxin yeah I could be wrong that you're
right who comes up with these [ __ ]
names
[Music]